many delightful things have happened on
this podcast over the last 5 years but I
maintain that my favorite audio moment
and this is really saying something
because I think we've had some great
audio moments but for me
personally was recently we had verer
Herzog great filmmaker director
documentarian verer Herzog was on the
show and we're chatting with him it was
an amazing I loved the conversation and
I think we got a lot of terrific
response about it I think you guys know
where I'm going with this at one point
he was talking I think about pop culture
and how he's yes he tries to stay
somewhat familiar with it and then
inadvertently out of nowhere he
mentioned uh a reality
show um and he I think he qualified up
by saying I'm not sure this is still on
any longer but then he mentioned the uh
the reality show and the name of the
show combined with verer herz's unique
delivery delighted me didn't just
Delight me but it it stayed in my head
for days
afterwards and um it's just this linge
that just keeps on giving it doesn't
lose its power it was 100% the last
thing I expected to come out of his
mouth exactly and he got the full title
nobody calls it that everyone just calls
it by the name yeah but he got the full
title he said it in his voice and then
the way he says it so Eduardo if you
would do the honors this is verer Herzog
saying something that really makes me
happy in 3 2 1 Here Comes Honey Boo
Boo I'm sorry it's the Here Comes Honey
again yeah Here Comes Honey Boo Boo it's
it how does that not cure cancer end all
wars how does that not reduce carbon
emissions worldwide immediately close
the ozone layer yeah maybe it will yeah
yeah I mean I feel seen because I I want
to say I cuz I think he's so he's just
on such a high pedestal but then there's
something he and I have in common which
the shitty reality shows yes and so
we're the same person yeah there's that
there's that but the best part is more
about the this the sound yeah to me yes
that's nice that's nice I get what
you're saying but to me it's about this
Here Comes Honey Bo boo boo listen to
the boo boo I know listen to The
belabored Honey Boo Boo in fact Eduardo
as we talk just pepper it in as we talk
whenever you like don't even wait for us
yeah Here Comes Honey Boo Boo yeah it's
the boo boo it's the Here Comes Honey
Boo Boo yeah that's very good but not as
good as this Here Comes Honey Boo Boo
yeah it's um I don't know I think when
it's my time to go which is who knows
when but people always talk about what's
what is it they want and I'm thinking I
want um you know to have a really good P
Noir I want to eat a really good uh
Sicilian uh thin crust pizza and then I
want them uh to start turning up the
dials on various things that will take
me to the next plane and then I just
want to hear this Over and Over Here
Comes Honey Boo Boo over and over just
go Here Comes Honey booo over and over
as I leave this Earth Here Comes Honey
Boo Boo Here Comes Honey Boo Boo I mean
I just want I I think that would make me
happy that's really the odds of that
happening in our lifetimes are just
astronomical and we got to be here comes
Honey Boo Boo yes the fact that has he
ever said that maybe he has but he said
it to us and there were microphones
around and we captured just we are
living in a time where verer Herzog
existed and here comes Honey boooo
existed and they met you're saying it
wrong oh sorry Here Comes Honey Boo Boo
it's Here Comes Honey Boo Boo Here Comes
Honey Boo Boo I want someone want to do
a dance song and just have that Loop and
loop that we have really creative fans
maybe someone can do it the question is
is there somewhere out there is Honey
Boo Boo herself
going I watch little I watch little deer
learns to fly I watch what little deer
learns to fly no what no no honey boooo
is probably I mean maybe it's possible
it's that it's your accent it's the
accent what is that accent honey Bo's
accent funny coming from you do it again
I want to see it I watch little deer
learns to fly oh say that she also likes
Grizzly Man I like Grizzly Man I like a
gir rat go oh that's the best one
yeah I like a g do that again I like gir
God and then Here Comes Honey Boo Boo
now and now let's do he's announcing
that she's coming with her F to say her
favorite movie and then you say and then
you come in uh honey boooo and say your
favorite movie and go Here Comes Honey
Boo Boo I like a GE wrath of God perfect
that's really
good do me a
favor edit in this is what I want I want
uh verer Herzog to say here that he
hears
footsteps okay and so he says here comes
Honey Boo Boo and then I want to hear a
door open and then I want to hear uh
Gorly everybody all say so here we go
are you going to do the sound effects uh
I can try and we otherwise I'll edit and
post did you think I
know artist no I was going to leave
space but anyway okay here we go here we
go here we go here we go All
Right Here Comes Honey Boo
[Music]
Boo I was the GE wrath of
God now now what is that does that I
think my door opening was okay but then
I did I think yeah that was like a
monster coming but also I think I was
you know what she was I think I had her
on a pogo stick I you
did the oh that's good yeah you do the
yeah better let's try it and let's try
it again let's try it again I can't do
yes you you're going to do it here we go
uh uh wait the the just so we have the
order it's got to go footsteps Here
Comes Honey Boo Boo door opens a gir wag
God footsteps are first yes here we go
and and
go wait wait what me what God what
did you do what was that piffy pit py
pit piffy pit what was piffy P what was
piffy pit I say we keep it just do it
try it again try it
again oh my God Here Comes Honey Boo Boo
then the
door I was a GE W go all right let's try
it one more time I'll get it we'll
tighten it up Sona
go Here Comes Honey Boo
Boo I watch the Gary wrath of God I
think we almost got it except what is
piffy piffy
piff why is she wearing a weird slipper
it's made of like well how would you
guys do the footsteps I that's a that's
a horse yeah she's coming in on a horse
or she's been Shaw what are you doing
she's tap dancing in come on no you guys
aren't
better why does she why does she
heartbeat walk um uh she has apib she
has apib a rare form of apib that
travels
down and it vibrates the uh the IT
band you guys are you got know I can't
do footsteps yeah except you piffy piffy
py piy oh I'd love to hear her anim her
do all the sound effects on a it was a
cold night wishy washy wishy
washy when the old man came piffy piy
piy P why joke when you can get her to
do it with his faithful with his
faithful Horse let's do the faith and
his faithful horse was with him clck no
why doesn't it
speak like that but why did you do
clickity clack I was walking the horse
was walking in and just then an alien
ship
landed
[Laughter]
so stupid and then they made all made
smoothies in a
blender that was a good blender all
right listen let's agree that as great
as
Sona was right now and as fantastic much
fun as we had good times we had nothing
beats Here Comes Honey boooo yeah amen
Mr Herzog you're our
hero